so I got some shock cord like this and
laborious leak at all the covering
offered to expose the natural rubber in
this the bungee we hid this some old
potato sack and I filled it up with
rocks and dropped it over the side and
it just hit the water
split dropping all the stones and that
was that test so I thought what doing
one more test it's gonna be me and I hit
the water so hard hey
right in over my head and I thought oh
well that such a little sudden I'm out
of the water again and I'm thinking it
works and that was the first modern
bungee jump that was the start of things
to come
while weekend's were pretty much taken
up with bungee different places
different crews teamed up with AJ and he
was at like mine like me the Newtonian
physics have been thrown out the window
has carry out and we advanced very very
quickly and of course every bridge was
getting bigger and better and Vega and
Eva's excited
H I was going over season we said I we
better jump the Auckland Harbour branch
so we drive up onto the bridge
everyone jump out with their little bits
and pieces down underneath the bridge
and we're ready to go what the police
said was whatever you gonna do don't do
it
AJ T's to me he goes did you hear that
hello it no did we just jump
I just move those but the Salone
policeman on the back of the deodar with
his mouth just gaping open a gender of
the Europe but it's in the story broke
and then always all guns blazing after
him AJ went overseas and ended up doing
some bungee jumping over there and kind
of drifted apart I didn't really get a
good handle on what was how commercial
it was going to be I was just really
testing the idea
you
you